The Joe Rogan experience that's on the other side of the planet.
Wasn't there book though.
We're like that happens and everyone goes to Australia,
but there's like a cloud of radiation coming that's eventually gonna get them.
Oh fuck.
Maybe we just get a big fan blow that shit to Russia.
I bet that would work.
But it should.
The China plan,
look if they can figure out how to nuke and entire country with a a few bombs
that drop out of airplanes or shoot out a rockets.
Build a giant fan.
Build a big fan.
Yeah.
Why is it so hard?
Like I was reading the shit about space junk.
Do you know how much space junk through is?
Like this stuff's a lot floating around in space,
like thousands of pieces of shit is flying around.
Broken satellites.
Is it all just broken satellites?
All kinds of shit.
Yeah.
All kinds of stuff.
Stuff from,
you know like when rockets take off and then they eject.
Leave little pieces of stuff up in there.
And,
and is it like in a ring like Saturn type of ring or is it just everywhere?
It's everywhere.
It's all over the planet.
It's like co,
it's in the sky,
like it's in the ocean.
It's like there's pieces of shit just flying around above our head and like they
have to be cognizant about it if they're going to launch a rocket.
Yeah,
like you could run into it.
Space debris and human spacecraft,
the all travel at speeds up to 17,500 miles an hour,
more than 500,000 pieces of debris or space junk.
Our track as the orbit earth.
Think of that.
They travel at speeds up to 17,500 miles an hour,
small enough for a relatively small piece of orbital debris to damage a
satellite or a spacecraft.
That's,
how was that movie with Sandra Bullock?
Gravity.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so it doesn't,
I just jumped.
The gun comes in and says,
yeah,
they're like fixing a satellite and something comes by and hits them.
Sit in the next thing,
you know?
Yeah.
Fuck that shit can happen and they don't know what to do either.
Like the throw a net up there,
what are you going to do?
I would think like some kind of like magnet satellite that would just attract
everything.
Right?
But then it would probably get too heavy.
I think we'll probably take out things that you need.
So yeah.
Is this the junk that we can track over time?
It starts at 57 there's only two things out there and then,
Oh God,
we're gross were so gross.
I bet the ocean's a similar similar story.
Wow.
Look at all this shit around.
Even worse.
Oh my God,
that's incredible.
That's all real.
I don't know,
2015 the entire low inner like near Earth orbit is covered with shit,
space,
debris,
satellites and nonsense.
I mean at one point in time,
and we've only been traveling in the space since the 1960s right,
so what?
When is this going to end like that?
That's not that long ago.
That's 50 plus years ago.
Were are going to do when it's a hundred years from now,
500 years from now.
I mean are we going to be able to see the sun?
We're going to look up and just see space shit floating over heads instead of
only 500,000 pieces of the earth is pretty fucking big still.
We'd have to get a lot,
I guess like I had a snap affected it.
So if you dug a hole through the earth,
it would take you 42 minutes to fall through it.
It's like how fucking big is that?
So it's a long,
long fall.
It's a long for Austin.
I was thinking would you stop in the middle?
He cooked.
I know,
but in theory if you didn't,
yeah,
if it was just a tube and zero temperature or neutral temperature tube,
I wonder how like how accurate Snapple facts really have to be called bullshit
on the Snapple facts.
Like I don't drink that shit so I don't read those things.
I didn't even know they had Snapple facts until you just said that.
I didn't.
They used to have like little things on the caps.
Like you say it,
it makes sense to me,
but I don't think I've ever read one of them.
I used to always read them.
No.
Yeah.
I can't remember any of you ever get angry how to snap effect?
No.
[inaudible].